responsable pour protéger chacun d'entre
nous et pour nous protéger comme nation
nos décisions se sont toujours fondées
sur la connaissance scientifique sur
l'impératif de nous protéger sur la
volonté d'agir de manière proportionnée
et sur la conviction que la
responsabilité individuelle et
collective sont notre première force
c'est cela qui nous a conduit à décider
à deux reprises d'un confinement quand
il le fallait au printemps puis à
l'automne 2020 ensuite à tenir bon avec
un couvre-feu et des règles adaptées à
chaque territoire au début de cette
année 2021 alors que beaucoup de nos
voisins fermaient tout
nous avons depuis le début de cette
année 2021 fut disposer de vaccins en
acheter puis en produire
l'Union européenne a ainsi produit plus
de 2 milliards de doses de vaccins
durant cette année soit plus qu'aucune
autre puissance du monde
s'agissant de la France depuis la
première vaccination en décembre 2020
nous avons injecté en 10 mois plus de
100 millions de doses
51 millions d'entre vous sont
aujourd'hui complètement vaccinés ce qui
fait de nous l'un des pays du monde les
mieux protégés
grâce aux passes sanitaires et à la
stratégie mise en œuvre depuis le mois
de juillet dernier nous sommes parvenus
à maîtriser l'épidémie
en rappelant ses choix et nos résultats
j'ai en cet instant une pensée à la fois
respectueuse et émue pour tous nos
compatriotes qui ont disparu et pour
leur famille et je veux à nouveau
remercier nos soignants nos volontaires
nos associations toutes celles et ceux
qui ont contribué à tous ces efforts
pour autant nous n'en n'avons pas
terminé avec la pandémie
d'abord parce que des dizaines de
milliers de nos compatriotes sont
touchés par ce qu'on appelle le covid
long dont les symptômes qui sont la
perte de goût d'odorat l'épuisement
la dégradation de la santé mentale font
l'objet d'une prise en charge spécifique
ensuite parce que nous le savons il nous
faudra vivre avec le virus et ses
variant jusqu'à ce que la population
mondiale dans son ensemble soit immunisé
et c'est pour cela que d'ailleurs dès le
début de la pandémie la France s'est
engagée pour donner des doses au pays
les plus pauvres et les pays en voient
de développement nous sommes au
rendez-vous de cette solidarité
internationale et nous continuerons de
le faire
nous n'en n'avons pas terminé parce qu'à
court terme l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé le dit la cinquième vague a
commencé en Europe
au Royaume-Uni en Allemagne plus de 30
000 nouveaux cas supplémentaires sont
enregistrés chaque jour
et si grâce à vos efforts la situation
en France est plus favorable
l'augmentation de 40% en une semaine de
notre taux d'incidence et la remontée
des hospitalisations sont des signaux
d'alerte
de même que la situation dans certains
territoires d'outre-mer où la
vaccination demeure encore insuffisante
dans bien des cas et qui ont beaucoup
souffert ces derniers mois je veux ici
leur dire à nouveau la solidarité
nationale et leur dire que tout
continuera d'être fait comme depuis le
début de la crise
tout cela doit nous conduire à la plus
grande vigilance
et nous pousser à agir
parce que nous avons fait le nécessaire
pour nous protéger nous pouvons
continuer à maîtriser la situation si
chacun d'entre nous prend sa part
mon premier message est ainsi un appel
un appel à l'esprit de responsabilité
des 6 millions d'entre vous qui n'ont
encore reçu aucune dose de vaccin
vaccinez-vous vaccinez-vous pour vous
protéger la vaccination est ouverte à
tous sauf aux enfants de moins de 12 ans
je rappelle qu'une personne vaccinée à
11 fois moins de chances de se retrouver
à l'hôpital en soins critique je
rappelle aussi que des milliards
d'individus sur la planète ont déjà eu
le vaccin et que nous avons maintenant
déjà un certain recul
vaccinez-vous pour pouvoir vivre
normalement avec le vaccin il vous sera
possible d'obtenir un pass sanitaire et
ainsi de vous rendre librement dans les
cafés les restaurants les lieux de
culture de sport de loisirs sans test
PCR
être libre dans une nation comme la
France
implique d'être responsable et solidaire
je compte donc sur vous
face au regain de l'épidémie les plus
vulnérables sont nausées et ceux qui
souffrent d'obésité de maladies
cardiovasculaires de maladies
respiratoires ou de diabète sévère
toutes les études montrent en effet que
six mois après le vaccin
l'immunité diminue et donc que le risque
de développer une forme grave réaugmente
la solution à cette baisse d'immunité et
l'injection d'une dose de vaccin
supplémentaire ce qu'on appelle le
rappel
une campagne a été lancée depuis la fin
de l'été pour tous les plus de 65 ans et
les plus fragiles il nous faut
aujourd'hui l'accélérer
si vous avez été vacciné il y a plus de
six mois
je vous appelle à vous protéger en
prenant rendez-vous dès maintenant
auprès d'un centre de vaccination de
votre médecin ou de votre pharmacien il
est possible de faire ce rappel en même
temps que le vaccin contre la grippe
à partir du 15 décembre il vous faudra
justifier d'un rappel pour prolonger la
validité de votre pass sanitaire
les personnes qui ont moins de 65 ans
voient aussi la protection conférée par
le vaccin diminué au fil du temps
d'ailleurs au moment où je vous parle
plus de 80% des personnes en réanimation
ont plus de 50 ans c'est pourquoi une
campagne de rappel sera lancée à partir
du début du mois de décembre pour nos
compatriotes
âgés de 50 à 64 ans
nous avons saisi les autorités
scientifiques afin qu'elles puissent
nous indiquer dans les tous prochains
jours les modalités pratiques et les
échéances à suivre de la même manière
que nous avions d'ailleurs organisé vous
vous en souvenez sans doute durant le
premier semestre la campagne de
vaccination
le vaccin pour efficace soit-il ne
suffit pas dans ce contexte de reprise
épidémique il nous faut en même temps
redoubler de vigilance tous les
assouplissements un moment envisagé
seront donc reportés pour conserver les
règles actuellement en vigueur
même si je sais combien cela est
difficile le port du masque à l'école
sera donc pour le moment maintenant
maintenu
l'application des gestes barrières qui
protègent autant contre le covid-19 que
contre les maladies contagieuses de
l'hiver doit aussi faire l'objet d'une
attention accrue nous avions tous un peu
relâché nos efforts et c'est bien normal
il faut donc les reprendre
les contrôles pour l'application du Pass
sanitaire dans les établissements
concernés et pour les entrées dans les
ports les aéroports les gares seront
renforcés et nous continuerons comme
nous avons toujours fait à adapter nos
décisions territoire par territoire en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
c'est donc grâce à la vaccination au
Pass sanitaire au gestes barrières que
nous pourrons continuer de vivre ne pas
restreindre d'autres libertés et ne pas
refermer des activités
enfin c'est parce que la France a très
tôt misé sur la recherche sur les
traitements et que nous avons su en
commander très en amont que nous
bénéficierons d'une nouvelle arme pour
lutter contre le virus avec l'arrivée
dès la fin de l'année des premiers
traitements réellement efficaces contre
les formes graves de covid-19
durant toute cette période notre nation
c'est toujours attaché à protéger chacun
d'entre nous sur le plan éducatif
économique et social nos enfants nous
avons été l'un des pays du monde qui a
le plus ouvert ses écoles nos jeunes
nous avons accompagné les étudiants avec
le repas à un euro et des aides
spécifiques pour les boursiers les plus
précaires grâce à une politique
d'hébergement social inédite et aux
aides exceptionnelles versées nous avons
évité après d'un demi million de nos
compatriotes de basculer dans la
nos artistes artisans indépendants
salariés entrepreneurs ont été
accompagnés avec le chômage partiel les
prêts garantis par l'État le fond de
solidarité et de nombreuses aides
sectorielles nous continuons et
continuerons d'adapter nos réponses en
fonction des besoins c'est pourquoi par
exemple les prêts garantis par l'État
seront prolongés jusqu'en juin 2022
nous avons aussi soutenu nos soignants
nos soignants qui ont tant donné durant
la crise et éprouvent aujourd'hui une
légitime fatigue ils ont été augmentés
de 200 à 400 euros nets par mois en
moyenne
500 établissements hospitaliers vont
être restaurés des milliers de maisons
de retraite rénovées grâce à un effort
sans précédent de 19 milliards
d'investissements partout sur le
territoire
ces mesures qui s'ajoutent à beaucoup
d'autres comme la fin d'une Mirus
clausus pour les médecins ou
l'augmentation du nombre de postes
d'infirmés font que jamais depuis la
création de la Sécurité sociale nous
n'avions autant investi dans la santé
il le fallait il le fallait après des
décennies d'abandon de
sous-investissement mais il reste je le
sais encore beaucoup à faire
cette stratégie du quoi qu'il en coûte
couplé au 100 milliards du plan de
relance que nous avons décidé grâce à
notre initiative européenne non
seulement nous a permis de résister à la
crise mais de rebondir plus fort
aujourd'hui
notre croissance dépasse les 6%. la
France est en tête des grandes économies
européennes le chômage est au plus bas
depuis près de 15 ans et nous sommes
l'un des seuls pays du monde où le
pouvoir d'achat a continué à progresser
en moyenne et où la pauvreté n'a pas
augmenté
nous avons réussi tout cela en
maîtrisant nos dépenses publiques
puisque notre déficit sera inférieur à
5% de notre produit intérieur brut dès
cette année
tout cela c'est le fruit de nos choix
collectifs
et
c'est aujourd'hui encore que nous devons
prendre de nouvelles décisions pour
rester maître de nos vies comme citoyens
et mettre de notre destin comme nation
pour les années qui viennent oui parce
que nous avons devant nous une forme
d'accélération du monde des grandes
décisions
qui sont à prendre
d'une part notre situation économique
reste toujours à consolider dans un
monde où les tensions sur les
approvisionnements et les coûts des
matières premières et de l'énergie
génère pénuries et inflation je sais que
beaucoup d'entre vous le vivent d'autre
part parce que nous ne devons pas viser
seulement 7% de chômage mais bien le
plein emploi nous sommes en train
progressivement tous ensemble de réussir
de faire en sorte que chaque française
chaque Français puissent par son travail
construire sa vie mener à bien ses
projets
notre économie crée des emplois comme
jamais au point que dans des secteurs
comme la restauration les bâtiments
travaux publics les services l'artisanat
ou l'industrie tous les entrepreneurs me
disent peiner à recruter aujourd'hui
au moment où 3 millions de nos
compatriotes se trouvent encore au
chômage cette situation heurte le bon
sens
pour la dépasser pour faire en sorte que
toutes les offres d'emploi soient
pourvues nous devons agir sur tous les
fronts depuis 4 ans le travail paye
mieux avec l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité de 100 euros au niveau du
SMIC avec la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et des pourboires avec
les baisses d'impôts inédites par
rapport au début du quinquennat c'est au
minimum 170 euros de pouvoir d'achat par
mois en plus pour les basses salaires il
faudra dans les années à venir
poursuivre ses choix et financer notre
modèle social en taxant moins le travail
encore
nous avons aussi beaucoup formé avec 15
milliards d'euros mobilisés depuis 2017
jamais autant de moyens n'avaient été
engagés pour la montée en compétences
des moins diplômés et des demandeurs
d'emploi
pour notre jeunesse aussi nous avons
déployé un effort spécifique avec la
réforme de l'apprentissage de
l'alternance atteignant en ce moment
même des chiffres records et grâce aux
plans un jeune une solution nous avons
aidé 3 millions de jeunes à trouver une
formation ou un emploi ou un
accompagnement ce qui fait qu'au moment
où je vous parle le taux de chômage pour
les jeunes et au plus bas depuis plus de
15 ans
pour les 500 000 jeunes sans emploi et
les moins qualifiés j'ai annoncé dans la
lignée de ce que je vous avais dit le 12
juillet dernier le lancement pour le 1er
mars prochain du contrat engagement
jeune un contrat est non un revenu parce
qu'au droit que nous ouvrons à savoir
20h de suivi intensifs une allocation
pouvant aller jusqu'à 500 euros
correspondent des devoirs de voir
d'assiduité de voir de suivre les
formations proposées et de s'engager
pleinement
plus largement pour que le travail
permette de vivre dignement et paie
toujours davantage que l'inactivité
nous conduisons en ce moment même une
indispensable réforme de l'assurance
chômage
depuis un mois les règles ont commencé à
changer pour rendre la reprise du
travail plus attractive dans tous les
cas et à partir du 1er décembre de cette
année une nouvelle étape va s'engager il
faudra avoir travaillé au moins 6 mois
dans les deux dernières années pour
pouvoir être indemnisés alors
qu'aujourd'hui les droits au chômage
sont ouverts au bout de quatre mois de
travail
enfin Pôle Emploi passera en revue les
centaines de milliers d'offres d'emplois
disponibles sans réponse dès les
prochaines semaines les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues
le 12 juillet dernier j'avais évoqué
devant vous la nécessaire réforme des
retraites
la situation sanitaire que nous vivons
et qui est en train de se dégrader
partout en Europe le souhait uneanime
exprimée par les organisations
syndicales et professionnelles de
concentrer les efforts sur la reprise le
besoin de concorde dans ce moment que
vit notre nation font que les conditions
ne sont pas réunies pour relancer
aujourd'hui ce chantier
pour autant notre volonté de sauver
notre modèle par répartition et d'en
corriger les inégalités n'a pas changé
ce 1er novembre la retraite minimale
pour les agriculteurs qui est attendu
depuis si longtemps est entré en vigueur
et dès 2022 il faudra pour préserver les
pensions de nos retraités et la
solidarité entre nos générations prendre
des décisions claires
elles feront légitimement l'objet de
débat démocratique indispensables mais
elles devront suivre à mes yeux des
principes simples travailler plus
longtemps en repoussant l'âge légal
aller vers un système plus juste en
supprimant les régimes spéciaux en
harmonisant les règles entre public et
privées et en faisant en sorte qu'au
terme d'une carrière complète aucune
pension ne puisse être inférieure à 1000
euros
aller enfin vers plus de liberté c'est à
dire permettre de partir en retraite
progressivement d'accumuler des droits
plus rapidement pour celles et ceux qui
le souhaitent d'encourager le travail
au-delà de l'âge légal aussi pour celles
et ceux qui en ont envie la retraite ne
doit être ni une contrainte ni une
angoisse mais un choix plus libre plus
simple plus lisible
aujourd'hui comme hier vous le voyez le
travail continue donc d'être notre
boussole le fil rouge de notre action
non seulement parce que pour chacun
d'entre nous c'est le travail qui nous
permet de créer des liens d'augmenter
notre pouvoir d'achat de progresser tout
simplement dans la vie en accédant à la
propriété en protégeant notre famille
nos proches en concrétisant nos projets
mais aussi parce que sur le plan
collectif le travail de tous et ce qui
nous permet en tant que nation de faire
nos choix et de garantir notre
indépendance
c'est par le travail et par plus de
travail que nous pourrons préserver
notre modèle social nos retraites la
prise en charge des malades
l'accompagnement des familles la
meilleure inclusion à l'école au travail
ou dans les structures adaptées pour les
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
par le travail aussi que nous
permettrons à nos aînés de vivre plus
longtemps chez eux ou d'être à
accompagné une cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale a été créée
elle sera pleinement mise en oeuvre dans
les mois qui viennent et d'ici au
premier janvier les professions du soin
et de l'aide à domicile auront vu leur
salaire revalorisés nous sommes en train
collectivement en ce moment même malgré
la pandémie de construire pas à pas un
véritable service public de l'autonomie
pour nos aînés nous le finançons et le
financerons par davantage de travail
c'est par le travail de tous que nous
pourrons continuer de rendre notre état
plus solide nous avons depuis 2017
recruté 10 000 policiers gendarmes nous
avons substantiellement augmenté le
budget de la justice d'une manière
inédite les résultats sont là
36 attentats déjoués la baisse d'un
quart du nombre de cambriolages et de
vols de véhicules des saisies et des
arrestations records en matière de
trafic de drogue mais très clairement
nous sommes lucides sur le travail qui
reste à faire la violence est de retour
dans toutes les sociétés occidentales et
exigent d'aller plus loin nous devons
ainsi poursuivre et renforcer nos
actions pour lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes pour mieux protéger
nos enfants et dans le prolongement des
travaux du Beauvau
une loi de programmation pour nos
sécurités intérieures est en cours de
discussion elle sera présentée au
premier trimestre 2022 et donnera plus
de moyens et elle légera les contraintes
bureaucratiques de nos forces de l'ordre
nous avons aussi lancé des états
généraux de la justice qui réunissant
tous les acteurs des boucherons au
printemps sur des mesures fortes à la
fois pour que la justice soit rendue
plus vite et que les peines prononcées
soient réellement exécutées
c'est par le travail de tous enfin que
nous pourrons bâtir notre indépendance
énergétique
nous vivons chaque jour les conséquences
de la situation actuelle le plein plus
cher à la pompe la facture de gaz et
d'électricité qui augmente ce que nous
vivons ces dernières semaines nécessite
des réponses d'urgence c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement a bloqué
les prix du gaz c'est aussi pour cela
que ceux d'entre vous qui gagnaient
moins de 2000 euros nets par mois et
recevoir une indemnité inflation
exceptionnelle 200 euros mais si nous
voulons payer notre énergie à des tarifs
raisonnables et ne pas dépendre de
l'étranger il nous faut tout à la fois
continuer d'économiser l'énergie et
d'investir dans la production d'énergie
décarbonée sur notre sol c'est pourquoi
pour garantir l'indépendance énergétique
de la France pour garantir
l'approvisionnement électrique de notre
pays et atteindre nos objectifs en
particulier la neutralité carbone en
nous allons pour la première fois depuis
des décennies relancer la construction
de réacteurs nucléaires dans notre pays
et continuer de développer les énergies
renouvelables
ces investissements nous permettront
d'être à la hauteur de nos engagements
au moment où nous allons clôturer la COP
26 à Glasgow c'est un message fort de la
France
vous le voyez bien et nous le
pressentons tous
dès à présent nous nous préparons à
affronter les défis de l'avenir
car nous vivons une révolution profonde
avec la pandémie nous avons éprouvé
notre vulnérabilité ce virus soudain a
bloquer le monde entier nous avons
redécouvert notre dépendance vis-à-vis
de l'étranger y compris pour des
produits de première nécessité des
masses que le paracétamol ou d'autres
nous avons réappris avec le vaccin que
l'innovation pouvait tout changer et
parfois en quelques mots avec une
rapidité inédite
en même temps les grands enjeux d'avant
la crise non pas disparu la protection
de la planète le défi démographique le
vieillissement la montée des inégalités
nous avons donc d'une manière inédite
tant de décision à prendre en même temps
tant d'investissement historique à faire
pour relever tous ces défis pour
maîtriser notre destin le marché seul ne
suffit pas il faut assumer une
intervention publique forte avec dans
quelques domaines clés des
investissements importants
des investissements de la nation des
investissements aussi de l'Europe c'est
pour cela que j'ai lancé le plan France
2030 doté de 30 milliards d'euros sur 50
pour investir dans 10 secteurs très
porteur d'avenir comme la décarbonation
de l'industrie le véhicule électrique
l'avion 0 carbone ou encore la culture
la santé le spatiale ou le maritime pour
éduquer et former nos jeunes dans ces
métiers d'avenir pour sécuriser en
France la production de composants et de
technologie essentielles comme les
semi-conducteurs la robotique ou le
cyber
notre objectif est clair que les
produits et les technologies qui feront
l'économie les emplois et en quelque
sorte les vides 2030 ne viennent pas
seulement des États-Unis ou d'Asie mais
bien aussi de France et d'Europe
certains pensent se rêvent
inatteignables je crois tout le
contraire je crois que cela relève même
de l'ambition faisable du volontarisme
lucide si aujourd'hui nous continuons de
mener les réformes les transformations
et si nous investissons oui la France a
les moyens de conforter ces positions de
grandes puissances éducatives
industrielle agricoles d'innover de
créer produire en tenant nos objectifs
climatiques et de biodiversité si nous
investissons si nous levons les freins à
l'action les complexités inutiles et les
corporatismes
mais la France ne sera pas forte seule
les enjeux sont-elles dans le choc des
puissances continentales qui se
déploient sous nos yeux que seuls une
entente européenne solidaire et
volontaire peut apporter à chacun de nos
pays européens un relais et une force de
frappe
il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux pour mesurer
combien nos intérêts se rencontrent et
sa corde
c'est dans ce contexte du choc des
puissances américaines chinoises russes
et de déstabilisation de nombreuses
zones du monde que notre pays aura dans
deux mois la charge de présider l'Union
européenne
car les orientations de l'Union ne sont
pas lointaines ou évanescentes
elles sont même la trame de nos vies et
des années qui viennent
sans l'Union européenne nous n'aurions
pas si vite disposés du vaccin nos
partenaires ne sont pas des étrangers
sur ce continent qui nous a été donné
par le destin ils sont confrontés au
même vague au même orages que ce que
nous rencontrons c'est donc avec eux que
nous tâcherons dans les prochains mois
de mieux affronter les défis qui sont
les nôtres ensemble de mieux protéger
nos frontières extérieures ensemble de
continuer à rebâtir avec l'Afrique une
relation de paix et de stabilité et de
croissance ensemble de mieux réguler les
géants du numérique ensemble de bâtir
une stratégie crédible de réduction de
nos émissions de CO2 compatibles avec
notre souveraineté industrielle
technologique
ce nouveau modèle d'investissement et de
croissance auxquelles je crois pour la
France et pour l'Union européenne et
celui que je défendrai en votre nom dès
janvier prochain en prenant la
présidence de l'Union
mes chers compatriotes
nous avons surmonté ensemble ces
derniers mois une conjonction inédite de
crise la pandémie ces conséquences le
terrorisme les désordres géopolitiques
et j'en passe
j'ai taché à la cavalcade de
retranscrire tout ce que nous sommes en
train de faire et ce qu'il convient de
conduire pour les mois à venir mais
durant tous ces mois nous sommes restés
soudés
fidèle à ce que nous sommes profondément
humain
alors je vois bien je sens bien
j'entends bien
l'incertitude les doutes parfois la
fatigue quelquefois la colère quand je
viens à votre rencontre qui se manifeste
la période est difficile pour beaucoup
d'entre vous angoissante
mais regardez ce que nous avons réussi
durant ces derniers mois en agissant
ensemble
Unis
nous avons réussi l'impensable alors je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de conviction
n'ayons pas peur
croyons en nous croyons en la France en
une France qui reste elle-même forte de
son histoire de sa culture de sa langue
de sa la laïcité de ce qui l'unit
forte de son esprit de résistance à la
dilution dans un monde de qui va à la
soumission au dogme aux obscurantistes
au retour du nationalisme
forte de sa volonté d'embrasser l'avenir
et de continuer d'assumer sa part
d'universel
croyons en nous
nous le méritons
vive la république et vive la France
Figaro live 20h27 et quelques petits
secondes voilà vous venez d'entendre et
de suivre en direct sur Le Figaro.fr et
sur notre page Youtube Figaro live la
dernière allocution du Président Macron
alors pour lutter contre la reprise
épidémie qui vient d'annoncer notamment
que le Pass sanitaire des seniors des
plus de 65 ans sera conditionné à la
troisième dose ce et ce dès la
mi-décembre et que les 50 64 ans seront
bientôt eux aussi éligibles au rappel
vaccinage il rappelle vaccinal pardon il
a également annoncé qu'un traitement
contre le coviste covid serait
disponible en décembre et puis ensuite
il a fermé ce chapitre covid et il a
donc déroulé son bilan agrémenté de
quelques annonces un petit peu pêle-mêle
on va on va y revenir en tout cas vous
êtes très nombreux à nous suivre sur les
chats du figaro.fr et sur notre page
Youtube je vous en remercie bonjour à
vercinger César tu cherches Agathe c'est
notamment sur le chat du figaro.fr
n'hésitez pas à continuer de poser vos
questions ou de donner votre avis et de
nous dire si Macron vous a convaincu ou
pas je vous lis et je relierai vos
commentaires en direct je suis en studio
avec Christophe de Vogue bonsoir
Christophe bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous au Figaro pour débriefer donc cette
allocution je rappelle que vous êtes
prof à Sciences Po politologue
spécialiste des idées et de la
rhétorique politique notamment
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
de ce discours bah écoutez j'étais comme
vous très très attentif de vis-à-vis
d'un discours qui fait partie des
discours plutôt longs on est on est à
près de 30 minutes en fait bon Emmanuel
Macron fait rarement en dessous de 20
quand on regarde l'ensemble de ces
interventions là il fait vraiment donc
dans quand même dans le discours je
dirais de longue durée de faire beaucoup
plus on l'a vu au nom du grand débat
mais c'est finalement un discours très
court par rapport au nombre de sujets
qu'il abordent et c'est une première
impression comme ça c'est on en a reçu
beaucoup dans les oreilles et le
président lui-même semble s'en
apercevoir en disant voilà j'ai passé un
revue j'ai noté l'expression à la
cavalcade c'est à dire qu'il a galoper à
travers
la forêt des sujets passés présents et à
venir de la santé au numérique en
passant par le cyber l'éducation des
jeunes enfin on a du mal à retenir tous
les thèmes qui est abordés
et des journalistes et je crois qu'on va
pas on va pas pouvoir rentrer dans le
détail de chacun d'autant que c'est
toujours un petit peu une petite
faiblesse dans sa rhétorique c'est à la
fois donc c'est accumulation sa tendance
à accumuler le nombre de destinataires
en mentionnant un tas de catégories et
puis un nombre considérable de sujets et
à se répéter puisque le tout ce qui est
numérique
investissement à venir on en a entendu
parler pendant à peu près 10 minutes des
répétitions pendant les dernières 10
minutes voilà donc en fait il y a eu
quatre moments si on regarde un petit
peu il y a eu un moment
il y a toujours un long moment chez
Emmanuel Macron qui est le moment de
mise en bouche et qui est peut-être une
des raisons aussi de la longueur de ses
discours qui est le moment de la
justification alors les mauvaises
langues disent du de l'auto satisfaction
mais il commence toujours ses discours
par dire nous avons bien fait
quel que soit le sujet et
particulièrement sur le covid nous avons
suivi les scientifiques nous avons fait
mieux que les autres nous sommes
exemplaires la France a une situation
enviable ça c'est vraiment toujours une
marque du macronisme qui dure longtemps
6 minutes quand même sur la campagne de
vaccination a apporté ses fruits six
minutes c'est à dire entre un quart et
un cinquième du temps total et puis
après les annonces covid
et puis qui ont duré encore à peu près 6
minutes et puis les ensuite bilan 6
minutes et ensuite
annonce à venir
donc quatre parties ce qui est beaucoup
de ce qui est vraiment beaucoup on va
justement écouter donc la principale
annonce pour lutter contre la reprise
épidémique que le président a fait c'est
donc cette conditionnement à la
troisième dose pour le Pass sanitaire
des plus de 65 ans on va écouter cet
extrait
s vulnérables sont nos aînés et ceux qui
souffrent d'obésité de maladies
cardiovasculaires de maladies
respiratoires ou de diabète sévère
toutes les études montrent en effet que
six mois après le saint l'immunité
diminue et donc que le risque de
développer une forme grave réaugmente la
solution à cette baisse d'immunité et
l'injection d'une dose de vaccin
supplémentaire ce qu'on appelle le
rappel
une campagne a été lancée depuis la fin
de l'été pour tous les plus de 65 ans et
les plus fragiles il nous faut
aujourd'hui l'accélérer
si vous avez été vacciné il y a plus de
six mois
je vous appelle à vous protéger en
prenant rendez-vous dès maintenant
auprès d'un centre de vaccination de
votre médecin ou de votre pharmacien il
est possible de faire ce rappel en même
temps que le vaccin contre la grippe
à partir du 15 décembre il vous faudra
justifier d'un rappel pour prolonger la
validité de votre passe sanitaire
est-ce que c'est une mesure cette mesure
donc qui a annoncé donc qui va peut-être
s'étendre à toutes les catégories de la
population infinie est-ce que c'est une
mesure qui qui sera acceptée par la
population alors là bien qu'il peut le
dire alors comme toujours dans ces
cas-là on reprend toutes les mesures
depuis le début Emmanuel Macron sauf
quand il y avait vraiment l'urgence nous
sommes en guerre Emmanuel Macron procède
par avec un calendrier c'est à dire
qu'il est alle il y a un sens de
gradualisme qui et bien sûr de nature a
essayé de faire passer plus facilement
bon d'abord il a raison pratique on peut
pas vacciner tout le monde en 15 jours
on se serait et puis on va donc faire
par catégorie des mêmes qu'on avait fait
la première vaccination par catégorie
sauf que là ça va aller plus vite
d'après ce que je vois puisque en
décembre ce seront les 50 64 ans puis
ensuite je sais pas c'est pas encore
c'est pas encore déterminé mais on sent
que alors cela dit est surpris qui veut
bien l'être dès qu'on introduit de
passes sanitaire quand j'ai l'occasion
de l'écrire
à plusieurs reprises
belle au mois de juillet on savait qu'on
irait vers par définition puisque vous
avez un pass sanitaire avec deux
vaccinations vous aurez trois
vaccinations puis quatre puis cinq c'est
vraiment inévitable avec une maladie qui
connaît des mutations des variantes et
cela donc était je suis étonné que les
gens soient étonnés si vous voulez
il est vrai qu'on les a pas beaucoup
aidé à ne pas l'être puisque on a
entendu là des choses un peu étonnantes
vous rappelez-vous pendant très
longtemps les deux doses c'était fini
tous vaccinés tout se protéger je vous
rappelle et là le président a encore
parlé de complètement vacciner avec deux
doses non ben justement on n'est plus
complètement vexé et ça c'est un peu une
contradiction dans la rhétorique il
aurait dû dire vacciner à deux doses et
non pas complètement vacciné bref on s'y
perd d'autant que
il semble qu'il faille le faire vite
cette troisième dose et qu'il nous
promet en même temps l'arrivée d'un
traitement et alors là peut-être c'est
quand même la contre-vérité manifeste du
discours la France a misé depuis le
début sur la recherche sur le traitement
ça va faire sourire beaucoup puisqu'on
sait très bien que justement on n'a pas
misé sur la recherche sur le traitement
donc là il y a quelque chose qui n'est
pas clair il faudra que le gouvernement
éclaircisse
ce rapport traitement vaccin qui est que
vous savez un des un des grands
problèmes de la situation actuelle
beaucoup de gens notant que on a tout
mis sur la vaccination peut-être qu'on
avait pas le choix mais on ne peut en
tout cas pas dire qu'on a misé sur le
vaccin depuis le départ ça ça fera
sourire les commentateurs
alors beaucoup de commentaires négatifs
dans les tchats sur notamment sur
Youtube j'en cite quelques-uns je peux
pas tous les citer mais sur la
personnalité en tout cas du président
Macron qui ne fait pas l'unanimité en
tout cas chez les internautes qui nous
regardent au Figaro Baptiste Leclerc qui
nous dit tout est faux Sergio 1977
quelle manipulateur ce commercial est
ombre de lune c'est de l'arnaque ils
nous enfume grave
quel est votre avis là-dessus à votre
avis
on est sur un médium particulier je
pense que si vous aviez
si on était je sais pas sur BFM TV on
aurait peut-être des réactions plus
favorables parce que ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est que
alors disons les choses déjà maintenant
c'est un discours électoral bien sûr si
on avait suivi la rhétorique après bon
le moment l'urgence ensuite le bilan
puis les projets puis l'Europe à partir
de janvier on attendait il manque une
phrase et quand ils annonce ma
candidature à la présidente de la
République bon mais tout le monde leur a
je pense suppléé donc à partir de ce
moment-là le discours est quand même
orienté vers le cœur de son électorat de
premier tour c'est-à-dire centre droit
il y a beaucoup de choses pour le centre
droit la valeur travail il n'existe
beaucoup là-dessus et à juste titre on
peut dire que s'il y a une continuité
dans le quinquennat et y compris par
rapport au programme d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 c'est la valeur travail ça c'est
indiscutable donc ça c'est de nature à
plaire au centre droit la
responsabilisation des chômeurs enfin
tout ça ce sont des thèmes qui parlent à
la droite la promesse d'une loi sur la
sécurité la nième loi mais que par
hasard elle aura lieu avant l'élection
présidentielle
alors qu'on n'a pas le temps de faire la
réforme des retraites ni de renouveler
le Pass sanitaire
et puis le centre gauche l'autre partie
du pain chronisme sera content de voir
que la retraite vont être augmentées le
retraite minimale que les gros effort de
formation que il y aura une garantie
pour les jeunes etc donc il a visé son
électorat donc il est pas étonnant
peut-être que que
on va dire que d'autres publics soient
moins moins convaincus la preuve
d'ailleurs qu'il a visé son électorat
c'est qu'il n'a justement pas mentionné
de sujets qui sont pourtant évoqués par
d'autres candidats d'autres candidats
mais on n'a pas dit un mot il n'y a pas
un mot sur l'immigration pas un et pas
un mot sur l'identité nationale à part
des généralités nous sommes un grand
pays etc donc
là on voit très bien que il laisse
tomber en quelque sorte parce que c'est
pas il a bien raison de le faire
d'ailleurs en premier tour ça n'est pas
son public ça n'est pas son audience et
donc il concentre sur son cœur de cible
de premier tour justement on va écouter
une annonce du président Macron c'était
une annonce un peu surprise la
suspension des allocations chômage au
chômeur qui qui ne sont pas en recherche
active
nous conduisons en ce moment même une
indispensable réforme de l'assurance
chômage
depuis un mois les règles ont commencé à
changer pour rendre la reprise du
travail plus attractive dans tous les
cas et à partir du 1er décembre de cette
année une nouvelle étape va s'engager il
faudra avoir travaillé au moins 6 mois
dans les deux dernières années pour
pouvoir être indemnisé alors
qu'aujourd'hui les droits au chômage
sont ouverts au bout de quatre mois de
travail
enfin Pôle Emploi passera en revue les
centaines de milliers d'offres d'emplois
disponibles sans réponse dès les
prochaines semaines les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues
[Musique]
ça s'anime ensuite quand il commence à
faire son bilan et qui est merveilleux
qui est vraiment formidable le chômage
qui a été qui n'a jamais été aussi bas
la croissance qui revient comme pas
nulle part ailleurs et puis
et puis la fin qui est tout à fait
intéressante parce que elle est elle
signale les grands moments du macronisme
qui est la conclusion vous avez vu
d'ailleurs c'est marqué par nos
techniciens nous le diront par le
close-up c'est à dire la caméra se
rapproche et là il délivre son message
final sur une voix quasiment religieuse
d'ailleurs il emploie un vocabulaire
religieux rappelez-vous il reprend la
phrase du pape n'ayez pas peur
n'ayant pas peur croyons en nous ce
vocabulaire religieux dit sur un ton
inspiré qui tranche avec le début un peu
je dirais intime
sur le ton de la confidence ou de la
confession on est dans un dans une
sphère religieuse elle a qui pour moi
est signe typiquement avec tout le reste
notamment la valeur travail
ce que j'appelle le synonisme profond
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est son
inspiration vous savez Saint-Simon qui
était un grand théoricien du début du
19e siècle et qui disait qu'il fallait
produire qu'il fallait travailler qu'il
fallait créer des richesses pour les
répartir en Suisse en faveur du peuple
et puis qu'il fallait en quelque sorte
aider stimuler et surtout se battre
contre les oisifs contre ça sinon ce
battait contre l'oisiveté vous avez
entendu là il faut être une recherche
active d'emploi et Saint-Simon a apporté
autre chose il apportait ce qu'il disait
ce qu'il appelait un nouveau
christianisme vous voyez l'idée c'est
son dernier livre l'idée que de créer
une nouvelle fois qui rassemble le
peuple français on est en plein
synonisme et encore une fois ceux qui
voient dans Emmanuel Macron a libéral ou
ou un social-démocrate en seront pour
leurs frais
[Musique]
du bon moment et là évidemment c'est
tout sauf un hasard ça correspond
évidemment il fallait qu'il intervienne
puisque l'épidémie reprend on va dire
qu'il fallait qu'il interviennent dans
les prochains jours mais évidemment le
jour de l'anniversaire de De Gaulle et
surtout ce message qui est un message
quand même que je dis majoritairement
orienté vers le centre droit qui est une
sorte de pieds nés ou à aux républicains
pour dire attendez le candidat du centre
droit c'est pas vous c'est moi et donc
c'est une c'est tellement évident le
jour où vous allez tous célébrer de
Gaulle moi je suis le vrai de Gaulle en
place et c'est moi qui vais parler au
Rassemblement du peuple français j'ai
envie de reprendre presque l'expression
puisqu'elle a dit il y a beaucoup
assisté sur l'unité nationale à la fin
donc il y avait tout un message
subliminal disant le De Gaulle
d'aujourd'hui c'est moi et votre
électorat c'est le mien
justement on va parler un petit peu de
ce format
c'est quand même la 9e allocution du
Président comme ça à 20h depuis la crise
du covid dans la douzième la 12e si on
compte les vœux etc le 31 décembre etc
mais pure covid on va dire que c'est la
9e on va dire que c'est un peu le
président des allocutions c'est un peu
le président des 20h c'est un peu son
moyen de communication préféré il avait
fait à l'époque quelques conférences de
presse mais il avait pas il n'a pas
continué on va dire qu'est-ce que ça
révèle de lui ce mode de communication
où il prend l'antenne à 20h
simultanément sur toutes les radios les
télévisions et puis bah les médias les
médias web comme ficaro live d'une part
c'est tout à fait gaulien c'est tout à
fait l'adresse directe du président au
peuple de Gaulle vous savez annoncer de
très grandes décisions politiques de
cette façon là on s'adressant
directement au peuple alors il est moins
conférence de presse
peut-être parce que François Hollande
était beaucoup peut-être parce que c'est
pas l'exercice qui lui réussit le mieux
je crois quand même que son meilleur
exercice là où il est le meilleur
indiscutablement c'est dans le débat
on l'a vu justement au moment du fameux
grand débat il est excellent face à un
journaliste de journalistes des
contradicteurs il est excellent face à
Marine Le Pen rappelez-vous et là le la
force de Macron ce qui serait une force
en campagne c'est quand même dans le
débat comme orateur il est on l'a vu il
est bon mais c'est pas de Gaulle quand
même
justement qui est un internaute très
fidèle de Figaro live je le salue et qui
nous donne son avis donc sur figarolive
il parle trop Mitterrand et Chirac par
les beaucoup beaucoup moins souvent
est-ce que la parole de Macron est trop
présente dans les médias
alors écoutez je pense que la pandémie a
tout changé c'est-à-dire que les gens
étant désorienté inquiets surtout une
population qui vieillit donc qui est
menacée par la maladie plus que que les
jeunes cette population qui ne cachant
pas qu'on n'entend pas qui ne manifeste
pas mais qui est sans doute le socle
électoral du président et qui quand on
regarde les sondages sur le covid et
favorable au passes sanitaire
majoritairement je crois qu'on
découvrira assez vite que les favorable
à la troisième dose on va vite le savoir
je pense qu'il peut compter sur une
majorité de la population sinon
d'ailleurs ça se passerait différemment
donc il sait qu'il a cette majorité
silencieuse dont il faut qu'il mobilise
une bonne partie pour pour les élections
et donc il a besoin de ce contact
régulier et comme la pandémie justifie
puisqu'il y a des hauts des bas on est
d'accord confinement des confinements
reconfinement en moitié confinement donc
il peut je dirais sans brusquer les
institutions ou choquées prendre la
parole parce que justement il y a une
urgence le temps dicte la parole
présidentielle et il fait ça pour notre
bien comme il nous l'a dit et que ce
soit soit pour resserrer la vis soit au
contraire pour ce qui préfère faire
comme tous les présidents soit pour nous
donner plus de liberté
si vous nous rejoignez merci d'être en
direct avec nous nous sommes toujours
sur le Figaro.fr et sur notre page
Youtube Figaro life pour débriefer cette
neuvième allocution ou 12e selon les
statistiques cette 9e ou 12e allocution
du Président Macron que vous venez de
suivre en direct sur figarolive vous
étiez très nombreux à nous suivre vous
êtes toujours très nombreux donc
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
à nous soumettre ou pour nous donner
votre avis ce que vous allez penser
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous avez été
convaincu par le chef de l'État je vous
lis je vous vois c'est pour ça que j'ai
mon ordinateur devant moi et Christophe
de Vogue qui est avec moi je rappelle
qui est spécialiste de la rhétorique
politique pourra donner son avis et vous
répondre
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur sur cette
réforme des retraites qui l'enterre
définitivement en tout cas pour cette
fin de quinquennat je vous propose
d'écouter le président
le 12 juillet dernier j'avais évoqué
devant vous la nécessaire réforme des
retraites
la situation sanitaire que nous vivons
et qui est en train de se dégrader
partout en Europe le souhait uneanime
exprimée par les organisations
syndicales et professionnelles de
concentrer les efforts sur la reprise le
besoin de concorde dans ce moment que
vit notre nation
font que les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour relancer aujourd'hui ce
chantier
pour autant notre volonté de sauver
notre modèle par répartition et d'en
corriger les inégalités n'a pas changé
ce 1er novembre la retraite minimale
pour les agriculteurs qui est attendu
depuis si longtemps est entré en vigueur
et dès 2022 il faudra pour préserver les
pensions de nos retraités et la
solidarité entre nos générations prendre
des décisions claires
elles feront légitimement l'objet de
débat démocratique indispensables mais
elles devront suivre à mes yeux des
principes simples travailler plus
longtemps en repoussant l'âge légal
aller vers un système plus juste en
supprimant les régimes spéciaux en
harmonisant les règles entre public et
privées et en faisant en sorte qu'au
terme d'une carrière complète aucune
pension ne puisse être inférieure à 1000
euros
aller enfin vers plus de liberté c'est à
dire permettre de partir en retraite
progressivement d'accumuler des droits
plus rapidement pour celles et ceux qui
le souhaitent d'encourager le travail
au-delà de l'âge légal aussi pour celles
et ceux qui en ont envie la retraite ne
doit être ni une contrainte ni une
angoisse mais un choix plus libre plus
simple plus lisible
alors abandonner cette réforme des
retraites pourquoi pourquoi l'avoir fait
c'est trop compliqué c'est trop risqué à
5 mois des présidents de la
présidentielle alors écoutez j'ai une
double impression c'est du vrai en même
temps vous dites abandonner non pas
vraiment puisque il dit ça n'est pas le
moment toujours le thème du bon timing
mais il en parle quand même beaucoup
puis il en donne toutes les toutes les
principales clés donc on sent très bien
que ça va être au cœur de son programme
avec visiblement peut-être une autre
réforme que celle qu'il avait prévu
puisqu'il a pas parlé de retraite à
points proprement parler il a parlé d'un
report de l'âge de la retraite donc il
est clair que il va peut-être modifié
encore une fois celui de centre droit et
celui des retraités qui est tout à fait
d'accord pour qu'on réorforme la
retraite des autres vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il est tout à fait il est tout
à fait compris cela et donc il va
il va la reporter alors ce qui est très
intéressant en revanche c'est que
l'argumentation qu'il utilise pour le
report des retraites votre ex exactement
pour la réforme du chômage c'est à dire
qu'il parle de la pandémie mais la
pandémie aussi pour le chômage il parle
de l'opposition des syndicats Dieu sait
que vous allez voir la réaction des
syndicats elle sera furax demain il
parle de la de besoin de concorde
nationale visiblement il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de voies dissidentes donc
pourquoi le chômage est pas la retraite
alors là le la raison est très simple
c'est qu'il a pour le chômage beaucoup
plus de facilité politique pour le faire
et beaucoup plus d'appui justement dans
cet électorat de centre droit il a
peut-être moins de de syndicats dans les
pattes on va dire justement les
syndicats vont l'effet hurler comme je
disais il y a une seconde mais enfin ils
ne se sont jamais battus on le sait très
bien pour le chômage il se battront en
revanche beaucoup plus pour la retraite
des régimes spéciaux et la différence
privée publique au moment de la retraite
alors ce serait une autre paire de
manches donc c'est très fort là elle est
la vraie raison pour laquelle il a fait
le chômage c'est parce qu'elle est plus
facile c'est tout politiquement c'est
pas du tout à cause de des raisons qu'il
a donné
il y a un autre revirement on va dire
changement de de position de d'Emmanuel
Macron également c'est sur le nucléaire
qui est qui est acté on va dire avec ce
discours puisqu'il annonce la
construction de nouveaux EPR alors que
il s'était fait lire sur justement la
fermeture de Fessenheim
oui je pense pas que c'était déterminant
dans son élections
qui doit se sentir mal ce soir c'est la
ministre dans l'environnement qui est
quand même numéro 2 de gouvernement qui
est quand même avaler la par une
couleuvre mais un python puisque cette
exactement tout ce qu'elle ne voulait
pas et c'est aussi très clairement un
choix là encore qui parle au centre
droit vous savez très bien que Édouard
Philippe a toujours été pour le
nucléaire Bruno Le Maire aussi donc le
tout a partie du gouvernement de centre
droit et pour le nucléaire les lectorat
de centre droit et pour le nucléaire et
là il est clair que Emmanuel Macron fait
le choix encore une fois de cet
électorat-là il ferme la porte on va
dire à la gauche écolo qui pourrait
encore voter pour lui mais bon combien
de division
ils regardaient sondages
illogne plutôt à droite on va dire il
est en plus de la droite c'est en plus
il le fait au moment précis ou les LR
n'a pas n'a pas encore de candidat donc
avant que il y a une cristallisation
en faveur d'un candidat LR c'est le bon
moment pour le faire c'est à dire couper
l'herbe sous le pied d'une candidature
ce qui fait exactement au centre droit
c'est ce que faisait Moore
elle a le droit de la droite
on va terminer avec cette dernière
question je pense qu'on vous l'a déjà
posé plusieurs fois en tant que
spécialiste de la rhétorique Christophe
de vol est-ce que Macron est un bon
orateur
j'ai tenté un petit peu de le dire c'est
toujours très difficile à dire parce
qu'un bonne caisse un bon orateur
ça change un petit peu selon le média
très important le médium c'est le
message disait un grand sociologue de la
communication donc ça change aussi selon
le moment les circonstances évidemment
le public je pense que ça n'est pas un
grand homme de discours c'est pas encore
une fois de Gaulle c'est pas Jaurès
d'accord ce n'est pas Mitterrand c'est
en revanche encore une fois un très bon
débatteur donc un homme qui redoutable
en campagne cela dit son niveau on vient
de le voir son niveau reste quand même
très élevé vu la concurrence si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
ce qui compte c'est le pas d'être très
bon mais d'être le moins mauvais
merci Christophe merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur Figaro live et sur
notre page Youtube pour pouvoir
débriefer cette dernière allocution du
Président Macron vous retrouverez donc
toutes les principales annonces dont
nous avons un petit peu balayé ensemble
certaines d'entre elles sur Le Figaro.fr
dans le papier ce qu'il faut retenir de
la dernière allocution du Président
Macron quant à moi je vous retrouve très
bientôt sur un pour un prochain direct
sur Figaro live à très vite
merci